syrian government forces
enter marat al-numan in the south of
idlib province
they're looking for rebel fighters from
hayat terer al-sham
an armed group with former links to
al-qaeda the town is largely deserted
and destroyed after months of
bombardment
its recapture marks a significant
advance in president bashar al-assad's
drive to take back
all of syria the general command of the
army and the armed forces announced
cleansing these villages and towns
and it assures that the army will
continue to carry out its constitutional
national and moral duties in order to
hunt down all remaining
armed terrorist groups marat al-numan
sits on the m5 highway which links the
capital damascus to syria's second city
aleppo
as well as to provincial capitals such
as hammer and idlib
before the war it was a major trade
route and the main access road to the
north
the latest drive by russian-backed
government forces to recapture syria's
last opposition enclave has sparked a
new exodus
on monday tens of thousands of civilians
fled towards turkey's border
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
has accused the russian government
of breaking a ceasefire agreement
in idlib there is now a movement towards
our borders and we have taken our
measures
since december it's estimated that more
than 350 000 people have been displaced
from
idlib province the increase in attacks
is worsening the humanitarian
crisis in northwest syria
but the assad government seems
determined to retake this final piece of
territory
still under the control of opposition
fighters
victoria gatenby al-jazeera